earlier this month or late September I
don't have the date in front of me the
Supreme Court declined to take up the
case to dismiss the defamation suit
against you by Dominion voting systems
for over a billion dollars why do you
believe one of the most conservative
Supreme Courts in the last hundred years
did not step in on your behalf they they
did not allow the appeal they were
waiting for the appeal they wanted to
the the K the way you're cured the way
you're saying you're misconstrued the
case we asked to appeal it to appeal the
case and they said no you're going to
have to wait till it runs its course
that's all they said yes we were trying
something there's so many things out of
the box here that haven't that uh this
these this law fair has now been done in
our country since 1798. remember these
guys sued over 200 people in platforms
it's never been done before where where
it shut up all the media around the
country instantly okay so what we're
trying everything uh and uh you know if
they want us to run which would be
normal you run your case then you do
your appeal we wanted to appeal right
now we're doing everything our lawyers
are doing to get this lawfare behind us
so then we can go hey you guys look at
it we have to get rid of these machines
and save our country on the machines
some of the comments of the electronic
40 machine including the polling books
the computers do you know that Wisconsin
has two million more people on their on
their poll on their uh their their
polling books their electronic um uh
database where they pull more two
million more people that live in
Wisconsin are actually on their voter
rolls and you say how do I know this I
have every State's voter rolls before
during who voted and then afterwards I
spent a lot of money over 35 million
dollars trying to get rid of these I
hate to interrupt you but that claim
about Wisconsin is completely untrue the
number hold on Mike let me just
saying hold on hold on I got it from the
Wisconsin Secretary of State you're
wrong who are you going to get it from
two million you can get them I did I got
requests out to every single these are
right off the voter rolls these are
their voter roles David who's sending me
the voter rolls what who's sending you
the voter roll get them from the
Secretary of States I got them from
every secretary you just said you don't
trust the Secretary of State I don't but
they have to give them to you it's
called a foia request you can but
anybody I have to pay for a lot of them
Alabama I had to pay forty thousand
dollars to hold on a second Mike the
number of registered voters on November
1 2020 in Wisconsin was 3.6 million no
you need to David you're not listening
okay
there were two million more people on
these things there's a thing called Eric
too okay those are the red or the voters
that are eligible and they're they
haven't been cleaned there was two
million more in Wisconsin just Wisconsin
alone two million more than than actual
can register to vote so to me they can
pull these names it's just like every
state every state has uh at least five
thousand some up to 50 000 people that
voted that don't live in the states
never happened before in history but
hold on a second Mike I we got to be
able to talk sensibly about this and I
think you and I can make some progress
well I'm just telling you I've got all
the numbers you're jumping around from
one thing to another and citing the very
sources that you tell me aren't
trustworthy when I cite them so let's
bring down the temperature just a little
bit Mike hold on hold on Mike hold on
here's the information I have okay the
population of Wisconsin is 5.8 million
and there in 2020 were 3.6 million
registered voters that's the information
I have which piece of data is wrong
okay my data came from the state I don't
know
Secretary of State well okay when that
when you're using numbers that live in
Wisconsin I'm telling you eligible
voters do you understand there's two
million more on the voter rolls more
than the eligible voters in Wisconsin
let me make an argument hold it David
you're doing the population of Wisconsin
obviously anybody under age can't vote
everybody that's not eligible they can't
vote right you got to take that off your
5 million total absolutely and you take
the voter rolls and they haven't been
clean I'll give an example in Alabama
they have over 5 000 people on their
voter rolls that are over 110 years old
Mike hold on a second they haven't been
cleaned let me add another piece of
information let me add another piece of
information
5.8 million people live in Wisconsin
4.5 million are of voting age
3.6 million are registered can you give
me the numbers for Wisconsin
oh boy you're gonna get him the vote at
the rotor roll numbers you know David
you should have told me I could give you
the exact numbers because I got them
from the states that's where I'm getting
them that's where I'm getting
I'm getting them from the States from to
the secretary of state of Wisconsin yeah
are the wec the web huh
yeah just tell just you can yeah get the
get the Wisconsin I want to know the
numbers that was over the registered
voters over it was two million some give
them the numbers okay